all right welcome to the stream uh not
the usual time not necessarily a normal
news day a few things I'm gonna focus on
today one of those things is going to be
the revelation not surprising to lots of
people that there are no Comey tapes
trump has no tapes
I guess although I'm gonna talk a little
bit about the language that he used in
announcing that there are no tapes
because some people email me saying
David you know he's not really saying
there are no tapes they're actually
still might be tapes they might just not
be his tapes or he might not personally
have the tapes but anyway we're going to
talk about that I'm also going to talk
about a really really weird sort of
request from the White House the White
House press arm is in total disarray in
the midst of the upcoming departure of
Sean Spicer the dejected outgoing White
House press secretary who's just been on
a basically downhill spiral uh since day
one of the administration when he was
forced out there by Trump to try to
clean up Trump's lies about a record
inauguration turnout and of course kind
of trying to defend the indefensible
they there there was no record
inauguration turnout and and so the
White House did something really really
weird today which I'm going to talk
about in a little bit but let's start
with the Trump stuff right so today we
heard from Donald Trump's Twitter
account and in fact I should pull that
up if we're going to talk about it just
so I have the exact quotes we've been
waiting for there's no doubt that it's
been weeks but maybe it's been months to
finally hear from Donald Trump whether
or not these possible tapes that he
alluded to possible recordings of his
oval office meeting or meetings with
fired FBI director James Comey he
alluded to the existence of these tapes
and when Donald Trump did that there was
sort of two possibilities right
possibility one was that Donald Trump
genuinely recorded conversations that
were taking place in the Oval Office not
phone conversations but in-person
conversations without the knowledge of
the other person in the room
uh it would have been sort of in line
with what Donald Trump had been known to
do in his private life as CEO of the
Trump Organization widely reported that
he would record conversations with
employees bla bla bla bla bla that would
that was sort of one possibility
possibility too was that uh Donald Trump
knew that he hadn't recorded anything
but in order to try to draw out whether
maybe James Comey had recorded the
meetings he suggested Comey better hope
there are no tapes which was always sort
of the least likely scenario and
scenario number three which turns out to
have been the correct one is there were
no tapes there were never any tapes
Trump never thought that there were
tapes and it was a tactic to try to
intimidate the former the fired FBI
director and whether that intimidation
could be part of a broader obstruction
of justice um uh attempt by Donald Trump
is of some debate within the legal
community and it appears that that's the
case Donald Trump posting today on
Twitter which is sort of like his de
facto means of communication at this
point with all of the recently reported
electronic surveillance intercepts
unmasking and illegal leaking of
information I have no idea whether there
are tapes or recordings of my
conversations with James Comey but I did
not make and I do not have any such
recordings so basically the 99%
interpretation of this is there are no
tapes there never were tapes Trump never
believed that there were tapes
there's just no tapes it was all a ruse
possibly part of obstruction of justice
to try to intimidate James Comey by
making him think maybe there are tapes
now if James Comey knew he was telling
the truth all along wouldn't really make
a difference to James Comey right but
that's the 99% probability but if you
look very closely at the wording of the
tweet and I'm reading this is all
written about in The Washington Post
link that's in the video description for
the live stream you can check it out
there
a couple people have emailed me saying
David Donald Trump is not denying that
there are tapes
he is very specifically saying he didn't
make the tapes could have been made by
someone else
more than likely Donald Trump did not
set up recording equipment in the Oval
Office if there is such equipment there
so that would qualify by as Donald Trump
not making the tapes and he says he does
not have any such recordings note that
Donald Trump doesn't say that uh he
knows there are no recordings or that he
is unaware of recordings he says he has
no idea whether there are tapes because
if he physically doesn't have possession
of these quote tapes and what physical
possession means in the internet age is
unclear but a couple people saying David
look at the language he's using he's
saying he didn't make it
and he doesn't have it if someone else
set up the equipment and someone else is
in possession remember Trump doesn't
really use computers as we found out but
at some point during the campaign Trump
may be aware of the existence of tapes
but he didn't make them and he didn't he
doesn't have them I think it's pretty
unlikely I don't think that that's the
most likely scenario I I don't think
that's really that's the type of
wordsmithing we were used to with
Alberto Gonzales for example but I just
don't know that Trump has the language
skills the linguistic skills to do that
type of precise threading of the needle
although you know who knows somebody
could have written the tweet forum I I
genuinely have no idea so that's the
latest on the tapes okay I don't know
whether it's going to go further I don't
know what ultimately will come of it but
I don't think that the revelation that
Trump isn't releasing tapes is not a
surprising one to anybody we're going to
talk more about this let me welcome you
once again if this is your first David
Pakman show YouTube livestream a few
quick things number one we're live right
now this isn't a recording unless you're
watching a replay
I'm live right now it's 9:30 5:00 p.m.
Eastern on June 22nd 2017 we are live
we're chatting right now you and I
number two super chat is on super chat
is
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window you'll see that we already
have three super chats or no I guess
that's two super chats that have been
sent so far you can use the super chat
to ask questions which I will answer or
merely to send comments which I will
read number three anybody who signs up
for membership or becomes a patron
during the stream I will sing your
praises live on the stream you will get
a live thank you and a shout out and
these are the two combined this is the
biggest funding source for our program
we're independent media
we're not like CNN or Fox News we don't
have these major advertisers funneling a
ton of money into our show the upside is
advertisers have no influence over what
I say on the program but we do depend on
the support of people through membership
at david pakman.com slash membership if
you want a discount off of membership
you can use it it's I voted 17 that's
the coupon code you can also become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show and lastly obvious trolling and
hate will get you banned the nobody
wants that okay if you're here to troll
and we notice it myself or the
moderators you will get blocked subtle
trolling will probably be fine as long
as it's subtle enough not to be noticed
let's now jump into some of the super
chat questions here starting with Frank
macwrite with a twenty dollar super chat
we all knew there were no tapes I don't
think anyone was shocked about that but
let's rewind have they just swept the
wiretapping claims under the rug is that
now a non-issue is that not some type of
violation that's right um the UH drunk
Donald Trump
prior to alluding to these possible
tapes of his conversation with James
Comey talked about Obama wiretapped me
and of course there's no evidence of
that as well and you're getting at
something Frank which is sort of
referenced here in a later Super chat by
Clark one two three four which I'll get
to which is it's such a constant stream
of nonsense and pseudo scandals and
actual scandals from Trump that prior
lies often are forgotten about
by more recent lies and indeed obama
wiretapped me who's talking about that
at this point i mean obviously it was a
lie there's no evidence of that there's
no indication whatsoever there was any
wiretap and now it's sort of missing
from the conversation so you're
absolutely right there Frank gr the
infamous gr has sent a five-dollar super
chat saying DS e I sent an email of our
ascent to greatness flip-flops are out
of the question
silence is golden togetherness that's
what it is love gr a surprisingly
coherent super chat today from gr gr
actually participated in a great
community building event at the David
Pakman show which is that he sponsored
six david pakman show membership he came
to me and said David I'm gonna pay for
memberships for six people who can't
afford them let's figure out how to give
them away last week I said here's how
we're going to give them away because
the person who's sponsoring these
memberships is known for incoherent
rants via YouTube super chat you are
going to submit if you want a free
membership your version of a gr
incoherent rant we had about 50 people
50 60 people submit rants I chose what I
found to be the funniest or best six and
those six people now have free
memberships for a year courtesy of GR
and for that we can all be very very
grateful thank you gr Clark one two
three four has sent a five Australian
dollar super chat saying David you ever
feel like you're overanalyzing Trump
like a fine art student writing a thesis
on a kindergarteners finger painting
this is a fair point and you know that
this is the president what we have right
now is a both unprecedented and an
unprecedented situation to use a term
that Donald Trump coined along with Cobb
feffy some time ago so I think you have
to find a balance between a few things
number one when everything is a scandal
nothing is a scandal so it's important
and I'm making every effort that I can
to focus on what are really the major
scandals rather than the minor scandals
and the medium scandals and the non
scandals and and only using the most
forceful language in those cases the the
reality is there's a lot going on that
the audience needs to be aware of and
simultaneously both sort of to round out
the show and because I think it's
important for progressives and Democrats
right now to be focused on issues and
not just Trump I have made a renewed
effort starting about two weeks ago and
I'm going to continue to build and I
think you'll see some of this
represented in upcoming pieces that
we're doing a renewed and strong
powerful effort to really dig into
issues and go deeper into issues we just
did political correctness we're going to
be doing a bit of piece on the so-called
the violent left we might be doing a
piece on classical liberalism that I
just thought of today talking talking
with one of our interns there's a lot of
stuff that we're going to be doing and
you know because Trump is the president
and Trump ist's are still here right I
mean the guys got 30-something percent
approval this is a this is a movement
it's going to be mentioned and related
but I think it's important to talk about
a lot of other issues and also you know
I like mixing in text stories and other
stories so I think there's there's a lot
to what you're saying Clark no doubt
about it
austan man has sent a $5 super chat with
no question or comment thanks very much
Austin I appreciate it let me quickly do
just a few thank-yous so I can get I
don't want to fall too far behind on
these if you do sign up during the
stream and I'm going to talk about the
insane non-reportable demands from the
White House press office in a second if
you sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership that gets
you all the member benefits including
instant access to the world-famous
Members Only bonus show I will thank you
during the live stream and I have three
such people to thank who have signed up
just in the first 12 minutes or so that
we've been chatting here first
it is Jonathan McNeil Jonathan McNeil
thank you so much for signing up
Michael Cousins has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership choosing not
to use the coupon code
I voted 17
Michael paying full price which I very
very much appreciate as well as beth
roberts beth roberts has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership and of
course if you want the discount off of
membership it is as simple as after
pressing that red signup button entering
the coupon code
I voted 17 into the coupon code field
and you will say 40 percent you can of
course also make pledges of as little as
a dollar a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show more thank yous up
coming hopefully anyway hopefully okay
let's talk about this insane story from
the White House and I am going to try to
I'm actually going to add a link this is
the source link I'm looking at I've just
added it to the YouTube video
description and I'm not sure how quickly
that will update or if you have to
refresh the window but give it a second
it's an article from Slade this is just
amazing the Trump administration has
number one been cutting down on the
number of press conferences that they do
on camera earlier this week they
actually at one point said no audio
recording either that was a still Sean
Spicer led one and the recent one was
that yesterday the administration
announced that today's press briefing by
Sarah Huckabee Sanders the up until now
deputy press secretary vile vile woman I
mean just just as bad as Spicer but even
more off-putting it was announced that
there would be no video but they also
said you are not allowed to announce
that we've announced that there is no
video in other words the White House put
out a statement saying this is a non
reportable statement there will be no
video at tomorrow's press conference so
clearly the white it I actually am sort
of relieved that the White House has
some sense of the reality that this
looks really really damn bad because if
they didn't realize that they would just
say there's no video tomorrow or they
wouldn't even put that out they would
just show up and say yeah and cameras
off at this point the fact that the
White House actually thought hey you
know what it might be bad if media
outlets start report
that we are saying we are once again
going to not allow cameras let's make it
a non reportable of announcement but of
course it was leaked anyway because it's
absolutely and utterly insane and it
this is just again this is part of this
entire idea that on the one hand
trumpets are not really going to sit
through a full White House press
briefing right I mean that's just it's
not what they do they're going to get
the highlights from you know a size 72
font headline on Breitbart or Drudge
Report bold with a spinning image of a
police siren they're not going to sit
through a 45 minute or however long you
know Sarah Huckabee Sanders goes out
there so there's really no downside with
the trumpets and as long as they can try
to do damage control in terms of
everybody else who realizes hey usually
there are press briefings and all of a
sudden they're not on camera
and there's fewer and some days they're
not on video that this this is a
concerted effort that coincides with
everything we've seen from the Trump
administration ignoring or simply not
caring about just standard conventions
that the media pool is used to uh direct
attacks and insults to media outlets on
and on and on and by the way I already
see a few people in the chat they're
saying that I'm fat shaming Sarah
Huckabee Sanders when I say she's vile
of her being vile has absolutely nothing
to do with her physical appearance I
could not care less about Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is physical appearance truly
although it's interesting that Steve
Bannon recently said the reason Sean
Spicer hasn't been doing press briefings
on camera is that he's quote gotten
fatter I wonder if that is a concern
with Sarah Huckabee Sanders who is
overweight but listen her whole um
paradigm the reality in which she
operates which is an alternate reality a
fake reality that's what's vile about
Sarah Huckabee Sanders I don't care what
she looks like okay let's look at some
of the super chats here a lot of them
coming in Jacob Saunders sent a one
British Pound super chat no question or
comment Thank You Jacob
Maria Romero has
- $5 super chat saying number one number
one makes me think number two is coming
at some point Maria number one what are
your thoughts about Trump being amused
over the obsession of weather tapes
exist or not listen what what does that
really mean that Trump is amused Trump
is amused anytime he gets attention
that's what seems to amuse him so I
don't think that his amuse being amused
is a sort of satirical amusement or
rhetorical amusement I think he the guy
genuinely is amused when people pay
attention to him Obama wiretapped me as
an example of that Comey better hope
there are no tapes is another example of
that I think it's simple narcissism real
quick people asking for our Amazon
affiliate link in the chat that link is
david pakman.com slash membership if you
want to buy on amazon if you type in
david pakman.com slash amazon it
redirects you to amazon and then we get
a kickback from everything you buy ok j
it up has sent a $5 super chat as a
veteran I don't see how veterans can
support Trump as a non veteran who has
been following veterans issues for many
many years I also don't understand how
veterans can support Donald Trump I
truly don't gr has sent a $5 super chat
no way to say tapes can play if the
witch hunts were in Salem back in the
day if we drown the tapes and they
survive Trump equals innocent we lose I
think that that speaks for itself o gr I
don't think I could really do anything
to that to make it any better
Jane womanpower has sent the five
Canadian dollar super chat and aside
wondering if you would ever share your
insight or views between Israel and
Palestine watch watch one of your videos
you expressed it it is complex there's
dozens of videos on my youtube channel
with my views on that issue I don't know
that there's any aspect of that that I
haven't covered Jane so by all means go
to to youtube.com slash the david pakman
show you can click on the little search
icon and search through our videos just
type in Israel or Palestine and you will
find endless hours I'm
in just binders full of videos binders
full of videos clarf 1 2 3 4 cent a 5
Australian dollar super chat David there
is nothing wrong with fat shaming
obesity is a disease oh let me I've
parsed it incorrectly due to a missing
period David there is nothing wrong with
fat shaming obesity is a disease and we
are experiencing an epidemic it's not
rude to say a smoker is stinky I think
there's a lot of false equivalencies
here Clark number one if if obesity is a
disease usually we don't make fun of
people for having diseases so if obesity
is a disease then making fun of people
for having a disease doesn't seem really
okay to me being stinky is a character
risk it's the characteristic of someone
who smokes cigarettes right they smell
like cigarettes
you could you could argue that that that
that is different than fat shaming right
I mean yeah I don't know I think I'm not
sure Clark love you but I think you're a
little bit off on this one
$20 super chat from Frank macwrite what
about trumps lawyer Jay Sekulow saying
that Trump is not under investigation as
he floundered over the weekend I'm still
unsure if it has been established that
Trump himself is indeed under
investigation yes or no okay Frank good
question how do I even like dig into
this Donald Trump it leaked a few days
ago over the weekend that Donald Trump
was now personally under investigation
by FBI special pricing or the special
prosecutor former FBI director robert
muller Trumpets initially said of it's
fake news and then Donald Trump went on
Twitter and explained that he was under
investigation but said that it's a bogus
investigation or whatever bla bla bla
then Jay Sekulow went on TV on Chris
Wallace but you're right Frank that
Chuck Jay Sekulow said Trump isn't under
investigation but in that same interview
within seconds he said Trump is under
investigation so Jay Sekulow is
completely out of this world he's
totally out of it and I think that if a
guy goes on TV and says in 90 seconds
twice that Trump isn't and once that
Tron
is under investigation I would maybe
just ignore his point of view on that
and even Donald Trump has seemingly
conceded that he's under investigation
Jay Sekulow by the way he's what we call
a Jew for Jesus this is one of the most
extremist sort of Western religious
sects Jews for Jesus there's two flavors
of Jews for Jesus Jews for Jesus can be
people who were born into Judaism but
believe that Jesus is the Messiah or you
can be born into Christianity but adopt
what is called a Messianic Jewish faith
which is sometimes something that
happens just sort of happens you can't
really explain it it's way more complex
than the tides going in and out like you
genui genuine ly don't know how this
happens because it bonkers
I mean it's slightly more bonkers than
some other flavors of this stuff
Messianic Jews who are there sort of Old
Testament Christians who call themselves
Jewish partially because Jesus was
Jewish bla bla bla
it's crazy anyway Jay Sekulow was born
to a Jewish family converted to
Christianity but then is a Messianic Jew
aka a Jew for Jesus I mean it's just
it's it's utter utter insanity I
couldn't even explain it couldn't
explain it in any way that it makes more
sense because it doesn't make any more
sense than that
sweet little vampire has sent a dollar
ad super chat thank you very much gr has
sent a $2.00 super chat I love Frank
macwrite love gr PS pay Pakman I don't
know if that means pay Pakman like I
should pay or if it's a message for
people to pay me in any case it's uh
it's it's pretty interesting okay let me
get caught up with some membership
thank-yous new members who have signed
up just what we've been talking here
okay that this is the number one way
that our show is funded membership and
if you want a 40% discount you can use
the coupon code I voted 17 as you see on
your screens here and something I'd like
to do if people are kind enough generous
enough to sign up for membership during
the live streams I say thank you one
such example is Leland
Sprouse Leland Sprouse has just signed
up minutes ago at david pakman.com slash
membership Pam Jones Pam Jones has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership thank you so much Pam I
really appreciate it Carl Williams has
signed up with the coupon code listen
there's no shame in using that coupon
code I want you involved at any
financial level that is comfortable to
you and if it's not six dollars a month
but it's three dollars and some change
per month then use the coupon code I
voted seventeen by all means
Christine O'Connor has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership i
really really appreciate that please
continue to sign up and also you can
make smaller contributions through
patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show my goal and we've sort of
stagnated we get close to 1,600 patrons
and then the first of the month comes
and some people's credit cards have
expired and we get knocked back down to
1500 and then we work back up to 1600 by
the end of the month and we get knocked
back down I would really like to get to
2,000 patrons and even a dollar a month
helps to make that happen let's do a
quick update on what's going on with the
YouTube advertiser boycott many people
reporting to me that they've been seeing
more and more ads on the David Pakman
show YouTube channel that's the good
part and what you're seeing on your
screen right now is truly a very solid
article by the New York Times is Amanda
Hess this was an article about the
YouTube advertiser boycott but
specifically about the David Pakman show
this is this was a big deal for us that
the New York Times actually wrote about
the show and about what's happening to
the show as a result of the YouTube ad
boycott you can read the article at
david pakman.com slash press it's listed
there
long story short as a result of a new
YouTube ad algorithm we've lost two
thirds of our YouTube revenue okay
two thirds of our YouTube revenue is
gone overnight and we're basically just
trying to make that up and this is
through no fault of our own this is
because of some large advertise
panicking over the false notion that
YouTube could not accurately and
precisely control whether their ads were
showing up alongside offensive or
extremist content this is not something
that's a problem if anything the YouTube
ad algorithm has always been much too
strict rather than too relaxed and then
just a few weeks after the New York
Times article came out Wired wrote an
article sort of a follow up by Devi Alba
and that one pointed out where we are
now which is that although we initially
lost about 99 percent of our YouTube
revenue we recovered about a third of it
right so we're getting roughly two
thirds the ad quantity that we were
getting and the ads are about half the
quality meaning that they are paying
about half as much so simple third grade
multiplication of fractions tells us
that by multiplying two thirds ad
quantity by one-half ad value we are at
one-third ad revenue on YouTube and I I
you know I always try to put a positive
spin on everything that's going on with
the show but the reality is that the
YouTube ad boycott is a really really
bad thing and you know I I'm hopeful
that we can continue to pick up new
member support and adding patrons etc to
make up that lost revenue but that's a
it's a big deal and I'm hoping that by
you know by the end of summer I would
love to go into the fall um with that
revenue replaced and it appears as
though there's every indication that
this is sort of the new normal on on
YouTube that our revenue has been
slashed about 2/3 and that that's the
way it's going to stay and it's it's
both low-energy and sad I mean I don't
there's really nothing else I can say
about it other than to remind you that
as part of the promotion that we're
trying to do of this if and when we get
to 2,000 patrons at patreon.com slash
david pakman show if and when we get
there
I will do an entire broadcast show with
my hair like this and as you can see
that compared
- this this is my hair controlled the
way you might be used to seeing it on
the broadcast show in studio on our 200
radio and TV affiliates this is my hair
out of control with no um sequestering
whatsoever done and I've agreed to do an
entire broadcast show with my hair like
that but again if and only if we reach
that 2,000 patron level at patreon.com
slash david pakman show alright let's
jump back into that was scary I know I
hope I should have issued some kind of
warning like if there were kids in the
room you should have gotten them out
before that crazy hair thing went on
screen okay let's let's jump back into
the super chat here gr has sent a ten
dollar super chat pact easy
please tell me who rants the best what
of them where have they gone were they
Trump nasty is it a problem show us
immediately or show us not immediately I
must know love gr must be getting late
where you are gr not sure what time zone
you're in but it must be getting late
that's for sure Nick Mott Cecotto
has sent a five-dollar super chat the
next news network is Trump extremists
how can how can we open a dialogue
without them shutting down and insulting
will they be rational and see facts
let's see the next news network
I know someone else has talked to me
about this before let's just see what
their recent videos are I think this is
the all-caps yeah I remember looking at
this before this is a channel spider on
the wall excuse me
got it
okay flying spider maybe not a spider at
all sorry folks
president Trump stunned the world with
what he just released about Obama and
North Korea that's the breaking news
from the next news network next video
Dems give Trump unreal ultimatum
impeachment proceedings will begin this
is wild I mean they've got half a
million subscribers and half a billion
views they claim to be your
was trusted liberty media channel it's
it's outrageous I mean it is amazing
that this is this is going on and you
know what what's actually making sense
there's a viewer at rumpus who responds
to me every single day she gets our
newsletter every day and she always
responds to me but some harebrained
conspiratorial right wing talking point
and I'm realizing I think they're coming
from this channel because what she's
writing to me about seems to match a lot
of what I'm seeing on this channel
Frank macwrite has sent a twenty dollar
super chapped appreciate that you do
this it's not often you get to discuss
these things with good reporters why is
Trump rallying now who has done this
before
is this common seems he just wants to
feed and hear the roar of his crowd yet
Trump is doing campaign type rallies he
did one in Cedar Rapids Iowa yesterday
where he blamed Democrats for
obstructing the new health care bill
which of course until today nobody had
seen right I mean how how is it
obstruction if you you just haven't seen
the bill yet you just you can't vote on
the thing you can't support it until you
see the bill he's rallying because he
that is an environment where he's
comfortable Trump is a narcissist Trump
cannot handle any kind of deep
questioning of any kind on uneffective
Lee any issue maybe on real estate you
know I've seen interviews with Trump on
real estate from 10 years ago where he
seems to know his stuff he seems to know
how to build buildings although maybe
maybe he was even faking that the best
situation for Trump is you show up on
Air Force One you read a speech
protesters are tossed out it's a
friendly crowd everybody cheers and then
you go back to the White House into your
fantasy world I mean that it's more
about trumps personality that's why
Donald Trump is holding the rallies Jane
womanpower has sent the two Canadian
dollar super chat saying thank you we'll
check your videos on Israel and
Palestine well thank you clarf one two
three four has sent a to Australian
dollar super chat go on the drunken
peasants again please I've said before
let's see how their channel is doing I
was on the drunken peasants some months
ago thanks to producer Pat
getting me booked on that show and at
the time I believed they had about
80,000 or 90,000 subscribers they're now
up to a hundred and forty two thousand
subscribers good for them I've said
before I'm glad to go on with them
absolutely any time any time they want
to have me I will go on they haven't
invited me back and it's a little
presumptuous given that I was on not
that long ago to try to invite myself
back on but by all means if they invite
me on I would be glad to go and I see a
lot of people in the chat saying hey
David you should really interview Sam
Harris I've invited Sam Harris on the
program many times he has not thus far
accepted there are many issues about
which I I would like to talk with Sam
Harris I would love to have him on but
it has not it has not happened yet all
right let me do a couple more thank-yous
to get caught up here major thank you to
Cameron Honaker or hone Aker who has
pledged $10 per month via patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
Cameron thank you thank you very very
much every dollar right now and
certainly if we can do it 10 bucks at a
time every single one of those dollars
helps us make up for the lost revenue
from the YouTube ad boycott also some
thank yous from the membership side of
things membership of course is the
number one funding source for our show
every day if you're what why is it good
to be a member
well there's any number of reasons if
you remember every day instead of
waiting for our individual stories to
publish one at 4:30 p.m. Eastern and one
at 6:00 p.m. Eastern and so on and so
forth around 4:00 in the afternoon
Eastern Time
you get a 1 hour full video of the
entire show for that day you can just
watch the entire thing no waiting around
for clips to publish without commercials
I might add you also get access to the
bonus show every single day we do our
our broadcast show but that's not all we
also do an additional 15 to 20 minutes
typically sometimes goes a little short
for our paid subscribers we talk about
other stories and if you don't like the
Trump stuff that's going on a lot of
Trump coverage get the bonus show
because there's very little Trump stuff
going on there okay
thank yous to new members who are free
to use the coupon code
I voted 17 to save 40% one such
individual is Samuel Hoglund Samuel
Haugland thank you truly thank you so so
much for signing up during the
livestream
I appreciate it as well as all of the
super chats and patrons who have been
signing up thanks to Ted Harris Ted
Harris signed up while we've been
talking here as well as as well as Jack
Kieffer Jack Kieffer has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership while
we have been chatting here and on that
note we do have more comments coming in
via super chat this next one from Zelda
freak 22 never got on patreon but to see
you do a broadcast with your hair like
that
I'm signing up now I'm sign up now and
my friend well by all means I if if if
this is something you want then by all
means the way to make it happen is we
get to 2,000 patrons I will do an entire
show with my hair like this and of
course it's going to be funnier if I
never reference the fact that my hair is
like this that will just add to it I
believe so yes make those patreon
contributions and someday someday I
think we will do it Tony Merritt has
sent a five British pound super chap
just finished watching the interview you
did with Josh Bernstein in 2015 is that
the closest you've ever come to
screaming at someone on the show it
might be it might be I can find that
interview just for people if you're
interested in it just so you don't have
to go searching around for it I will add
this interview to the video description
in a second I'm just searching our
YouTube channel for it yeah Josh
Bernstein is just insufferable and the
thing is he is very much impacted by the
dunning-kruger effect the dunning-kruger
effect is is a concept that relates to
people lacking the capacity to
understand
that they don't understand something and
there's no doubt that Josh Bernstein
experienced that and I just added the
interview that Tony is referring to to
the video description for the live
stream you might after I don't know if
it will automatically update you may
have to refresh the stream in order to
see that but yeah that's a doozy that is
a doozy and let's see maybe I can link
it in the chat I will send it in the
chat right now there it is
so let's see if that um did watch it
after the stream it's it's pretty
compelling stuff I'm not going to lie
and on that note I also want to send out
just one more thank you via patreon to
AJ at alati
I don't know if AJ at alladhi is the
same person as Zelda freak but the
timing of it seems to coincide seems to
coincide so big thanks to AJ Atta Lottie
I really really appreciate that that's
it for today just a quick live stream
wanted to talk about the trump tape
stuff but we've got so much new content
coming up for you guys thanks to
everybody really appreciate everybody
who joined up with the show either
figuratively or literally through
membership but even just our YouTube
subscriptions closing in on 400 thousand
thanks to everybody in and I'm hopeful
that we will persevere through the
YouTube ad boycott and get back to full
strength hopefully sooner than later
ideally within a few months